io lo sapevo e benvenuti in questo
nuovissimo episodio di minecraft siamo
tornati ragazzi e sono contentissimo nel
fatto che è riuscito a portare gli
avanti nell'ultimo episodio meno male
perché almeno stavolta manca però la
cosa principale che dall'episodio dove
la porto avanti che il portare a casa
fernando e adesso abbiamo tutte le carte
in regola per farlo voglio assolutamente
fare questa cosa
il prima possibile perché con fernando
possiamo appunto andare in giro per il
mondo a cercare delle cose nuove in giro
esplorare fare cose tipo dora
l'esploratrice qui andiamo a prendere
fernando abbiamo la nostra scala per
salire ormai tutto a posto allora ho
cercato di fare una radura qua per poter
fare appunto recinto per fermando perché
comunque fermando avrà il suo recinto
però è un po un casino anche perché casa
mia adesso lui la vedete così ma poiché
avanti la grandi lo farò anche su altre
a su altri alberi o altre cose vorrei
fare anche una torre qua in mezzo al
lago
vediamolo 6 fernando eccolo il mio
fernando meraviglioso che è rimasta
nella foresta tutto questo tempo ciò che
l'oro come stai
allora sei proprio qua no che questa tua
sorella ti porto via la quale che non so
che è molto pericoloso allora fernando e
a chiazze allora ne intacca est e galdo
no il pane poi c'è scritto lì devo avere
della grano maledizione non lo sapevo
porco demonio non ce l'ho io il grano
come lo coltivo il vero devo andare a
[ __ ] del grano amarci o ai ragazzi si
tratta di due spighe per poi poterlo
utilizzare con fernando perché se non un
modo porco il demonio ad amarci 100
ragazzi che il casinò è proprio questo
cioè nel senso non ci ha pensato proprio
sta roba di grano potrato io post
aspetta liberati i figli di bella faccia
che sono napoli ma che ci sono e cosa di
state fair e che ho visto liste pfeiffer
e not cambiato spawn point porco demonio
torna in casa mia come surfer e scusate
una ti prendo in prestito un grano basta
uno
anzi ne prendi per fido di più poi ve lo
riporto poi tanto ne avete tanto anzi
para il rimpianto faccio prima gli ori
piantato tempo che rigiocate mi crescere
europeo 16 ore e mezza allora la carota
tela dono tanta meriti ottimo dato un
miliardo e non rompere no ragazzi
veramente ce le ho dato tutto anche
guadagnando all'altro piccola scala
ma cosa vuoi scusa ma perché io ho dato
tutto ed è allora la sella molto bene
non serve la serata andare più veloce
nei tag che lo metto ma come faccio
aspetta aspetta aspetta fernando e lo
devo uscire e come glielo metto in lenta
di scusa ma serve il le ville ma va a
cagare cioè fernando mi stai costando
un'eresia provate dai ce la faremo dai
ce la faremo
intanto ragazzi mettiamo il recinto per
fernando poi pensiamo a mettere
l'incudine porca vacca sa che non lo
sapevo questa è tutta roba che non c'era
i tempi che ragazzo spianato qualsiasi
cosa tra l'altro oltre che farmi tutto
il resto e quindi mi sto ricostruendo
tutto perché effettivamente posso farla
molto meglio ragazzi sto rifacendo tutto
perché ho avuto un'idea incredibile
allora o spianato un po tutto
teoricamente dovrebbe bastare sta roba
per farci recinto intorno ad esso
iniziano a farlo tipo così ok non so se
basta è perché hanno fatto 64 ma
potrebbe anche effettivamente non
bastare vamonos sull'ultimo pezzo ho
fatto tutto il recinto carino ci posso
toccare dentro fermando e poi andiamo a
vedere
per lei pil che quella cosa che mi
servirà un sacco perché sono le
scommettere lenta leger fernandino ci ho
messo due ore ma ci siamo vieni qua
ecco allora vesco a fare il giro è
sempre casino muovere il cavallo nella
giungla è però let's go eva mon o la
bellissimo devo fare tutto molto più
accogliente ovviamente ma per adesso per
iniziare ti direi che
direi che va benissimo da wordpress la
teniamo qua mettiamo che sto casino ma
si sta spaccando per l'orto l'altro di
quanta mikako addosso sarebbe mega utile
adesso riuscire a mettere a posto di
riuscire a fare lembi il perché è una
cosa molto complicata all'inizio
soprattutto se non hai mai giocato a
minecraft negli ultimi vent'anni sono
successe le peggio cose lembi ci serve
per mettere in lenta quindi let's go
ma il braccio fatto tutto ok ok abbiamo
36 pezzi e giusto quindi non è che poi
mi faccio i blocchi e per non servono
allora allora vediamo 1 2 e 3
ok blocco file on li metto qua e mi
faccio questo ho una volta che facciamo
per funziona voglio non voglio credere
ok anvil che va assolutamente messa al
piano di sotto io la metto quale
ambiente perfetto o adesso ne in tag
fernando quel punto esclamativo fermando
col punto esclamativo eccolo qui grazie
ho usato un punto esperienza ma fa
niente
fernando arrivo arrivo con la roba ci ho
messo due ore a far tutto sto casino
recinto e per oggi abbiamo dedicato la
puntata beh signori abbiamo tutto il
fernando ha posto guarda che roba
guarda che roba vi sono prodotte sarah
che si erano mischiati fernando sua
moglie e chiude la serie allora fernando
ce l'abbiamo bello carico con le evil
nominato tutto fatto usato un sacco di
metallo per riuscire a fare questa cosa
ma l'importante è che sia venuto fuori
bene bene
adesso abbiamo questo abbiamo tutto
possiamo fare spedizione manetta perché
abbiamo un sacco di materiali possiamo
fare tutto ragazzi direi di andare poi a
dare un'occhiata per vedere se riesco ad
andare nell'etere a raccogliere qualcosa
per andare nelle
io utilizzerei un portale che poi però
fatto l'utilizzo direttamente quello
tanto ledere 1 vediamoli andarci proprio
anni farlo teoricamente non mi dovrei
fare il piccone perché poi alla fine con
questa roba fatta cioè che cosa tengo a
fare qua non la devi fare anche il
piccolo in diamante dovrei migliorare
casa però sono tutte cose che faccio poi
col tempo mi pagato un altro picco nel
ferro perché effettivamente questo fa
mise io non voglio mai usare con gli
diamante a casa quindi prendo
direttamente questo quadro non so
effettivamente dove potrei trovare delle
barbe basta scendere effettivamente
nelle caverne poi sono ancora vicino a
casa mia
cioè saremo abu 200 blocchi l'importante
comunque che si trovi della valle la
lava si trova ovunque ragazzi avevo
trovato anche con step vicino però
voglio andare di sotto perché nel mentre
se ne trova di più tra l'altro c'era
dell'ossidiana proprio vicino a casa mia
perché se fa l'aveva trovata aveva
trovato un portale già quasi costruito
quindi potevo prenderlo anche nei
succede però almeno ne va a farsi un po
di di spedizione perché mi serve di
nuovo il ferro che ho utilizzato tutto
per costruire prepara nei tag e oa
quell'altro aveva appena detto che non
volevo usare il piccolo diamante a
calcio ma chi se ne frega cioè la roba
qui aiuto cioè della roba incredibile mi
ha dato qualcosa da smith barris mandata
una sega aiuto scavati nei piedi devo
prendere al commesso di mettere la sopra
ok ok meno male meno vale provare il
servizio però la pace la faccio
ok ho rischiato la morte tantissimo
troppo ma fa niente o tutto sto casino
per trovare della lava per l'ossidiana
già niente di gara un settore ma sentono
sito nord ecco ecco la croce la sola
nice
il signor favi la trova così quella roba
lì parte 26 che non è che sono sfondi
clipper sto male non creare una
sponibile nice
quindi c'è un altro piparo
uno sfondo loro ancora più fieri
lapislazzuli se proprio vogliamo ne
prendo giusto un paio a giusto per avere
qualcosa ma che cacchio me ne faccio
dell'oro qualcuno ha rubato l'avete
sentito anche voi va bene dai torniamo a
parco demonio e spronato nel mentre sto
pezzente
ma ho messo le torce ma scusa sono messo
le torce non è neanche esploso come va
beh se sparate pure con le torce
fratelli miei che vi devo dire
mamma mia quanto stiamo in totale di
roba 47 di ferro non male non vale meno
male che ho fatto la spedizione allora
ragazzi al momento ci butta una
secchiata e via miniamo stamane eletto
siliana va mano mentre certi qua credo
abbiamo tutto ci siamo mai go race è il
momento di minare l'ossidiana e servono
tipo 12 se non erro ok my boys dovremmo
esserci vabbè dai sigg anzi bastano
fatto un sacco fatto anche un paio di
più per essere proprio sicuro al 3 mila
per cento che non manchi niente allora
dobbiamo solo uscire e abbiamo fatto
facciamo la nostra tattica usciamo
normalmente riuscirai normalmente cioè
l'on scavandomi intestavano houches
skies casino ma fuori andare così ci
mette sono sbloccato nella miniera
c'è una cesta pure c'è incredibile c'è
un'altra età un altro fernando non mi
sarei più lamenta anche però del pane e
volentieri grazie poi fatto un bel po di
roba c'è anche un sacco di ferro lo so
non l'ho sempre in alto però mamma mia
quanto ci metto a uscire lo so ma che
palle
allora gli ori qua va di qua perché
illuminato forse c'è qualche forza ero
già passato di qua tipo può essere
pensare che qua a ecco che dicano già
passato porca vacca e quindi qualcosa
vai vai vai vecchia vedo altra roba non
toccata a noi sono legni vabbè non fa
niente vai vai vai vai vai la legge un
creeper ricambia strada o absoluto e il
super
però anche le caverne questa va proprio
sopra mi sembra sta cadendo fiato la
morte se va della mossa stone
selezionatore non ci credo mai non ci
credo mai non ci credo mai non ci credo
mai trovato un altro trovato dungeon
porco demoni e spettacolo di ragni stato
l'altro lancio non ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere c'è una nei tag
oddio la golden al board per fernando
non ci muove a ben nove ragazzi no vabbè
ragazzi non abbia non ci credo non ci
voglio credere
ho trovato tutto tutto la col denaro e
moro trovato né integration vai perfetto
buonissimo ragazzi che culo c'è mentre
uscivo ha trovato il viaggio alla
pazzesca tra emo facciamo clipper lo
faccio non ho trovato un'altra un'altra
sella ma chi se ne frega l'importante
lane trotta jonathan thonon non devo
dovessi carpi nessuno più che altro ho
trovato questo la gode
avrei preferito trovare la diamond però
vabbè dai chissenefrega cioè a caval
donato non si guarda in bocca in questo
caso va a mons
io sto sfruttata ma ci credo cosa
aspettate a casa di ferie padrone ma
cosa ma quante pro vita c'erano che donò
va beh non ci voglio credere
non ci vanno ragazzi no va bene non lo
so non so come descrivere questa cosa ve
lo giuro ma con quante provavi il nome
in pazzesco vi giuro come con quante
probabilità potevo cascare fuori dalla
casa di steve fare questo casino con
quante poche impossibile
c'era un dungeon sotto casa di steve
fair è proprio un metro guarda veramente
non ho parole meraviglioso la grave dai
tornava a casa prossimo episodio ne
inter ne so proprio ciao ragazzi
prossimo episodio come se tu sei il
video è piaciuta lasciato belhaj sia io
che fernando che è coperto nella pioggia
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
e la ragazza
[Musica]